a british nhs doctor an irish citizen
who lived there for more than 20 years
and a pharmacist from birmingham all
accused of being islamic state fighters
and now in jail in east syria the men
were arrested separately
amongst the crowds of civilians fleeing
the militants
now on the brink of being defeated
militarily they have one thing in common
i'm not an isis person i'm not i'm not
part of them i'm not a terrorist i'm
ordinary person
no i'm not a danger i'm not a danger i
came here to do humanitarian work
mohammed anwar the pharmacist was filmed
by his captors
when arrested last august i've been here
for
just under four years under four years
yeah he was in a
dash with dash i'm a doctor you're a u.s
doctor
i'm a qualified pharmacist from the uk i
studied medicine and pharmacy
yes but why you come here i came here
to work with the general people and to
help people working their general
hospitals
hi i'm alex crawford from sky
news when we met him on a kurdish base
with guards overseeing us
he was still protesting his innocence i
can say to the
everybody in britain that i'm i'm not
i'm not i'm not an isis fighter i'm not
a dangerous person
i came here to do humanitarian work i
have heard nobody
i have done nothing wrong other than
work in hospital
people have labeled me with isis because
of the area was controlled by isis
but i just did my job working in a
hospital
for three and a half years he was inside
is territory
when the extremists were at their
strongest controlling large areas of
land in syria and iraq
carrying out executions amputations and
beheadings
but the birmingham pharmacist insists he
saw virtually nothing
very very little very very little when i
first got
the internet was always very weak and
then they went through a period whereby
they said the internet is not allowed
and then
they said the television is not allowed
and they removed everybody's dishes
and they put them in one place and it
was it was forbidden to have a
television in your house
wasn't that a bit of an alarm bell that
things might be going wrong
um
in mayor dean everything was fine but
the coalition of western governments
including britain
which supported the fight against is are
now refusing to repatriate citizens like
muhammad al-wamir
claiming they could carry out attacks
back home
what is it you miss about britain i miss
everything the choice
the choice um you know
and the freedom the choice and the
freedom you know i
i can walk into a supermarket and
everything is available
i can have the freedom to choose
anything i want
yeah the kurdish forces holding the is
suspects haven't been able to conduct
trials and don't want the responsibility
of people they view as militants
especially with the region so fragile
their foreign captives are in limbo
and getting desperate why am i still
sitting in the prison
why i'm not being given any justice is
there no justice britain exists it's the
strongest
one of the strongest countries in the
world and
why my country has abandoned me when i
needed it the most
the doctor who's worked in dozens of nhs
hospitals
says he was duped into going into is
territory and then kidnapped
he was there for two years i never
realized how much
i would miss my home i how much england
meant to me really
so for me it is my home i was a very
good doctor
a good profession a good human being
there is not a single complaint in nhs
against me
i've been excellent with people and i
have got some special skills
alexander pekmir zayev is an irish
passport holder who's lived in dublin
but left for syria
in 2013 urging his wife to bring their
baby son and join him months later
what can i do that's the biggest mistake
of my life what
what else
i lost five and a half years i stole
five and a half years from my family
he and his family emerged weak and
starving a few weeks ago from the last
pocket held by is
he insists he was forced by is to drive
injured people to hospitals they told me
you must work now you can't sit like
that i said well i'm not gonna go fight
i can't first of all i physically i can
do this
i said no we're not asking you to fight
i have to like
bring the families to to the hospitals
in memphis sometime
alba sometime raqqa and that's what i
did
for over a year towards the end towards
the last six months
it was like this you don't fight you
don't eat
i didn't fight i didn't eat
i eat grass my family eat a grass
the worry now is in the dying days of
the battle against is
his kurdish captors may lose territory
to either turkey
or the syrian regime's bashar al-assad
and that'll mean losing control of their
foreign prisoners
well i don't know if we're going to end
up in the custody of bashar we're going
to get killed
this is definitely he will kill us
the military fight against is may be all
but over
but the region's as unstable as ever and
thousands accused of being foreign
islamic state fighters
are wanted by neither their home
countries or their captors
alex crawford sky news in eastern syria